when the announcement came that the
majority of conservative lawmakers do
have confidence in Teresa may her
supporters could breathe the sigh of
relief but not everyone could share the
joy about one third of May's own party
voted against her the Prime Minister's
critics think she should resign she
cannot get her deal through her very bad
unsatisfactory withdrawal agreement
which is not supported by the DUP by
many conservatives or by the opposition
and having failed in her main plank of
policy it would be constitutionally
normal for her to retire from the fray
after weeks of speculation about how
much support Mae had from within her own
party enough letters were sent to
trigger a confidence vote on her
leadership some conservative politicians
are unhappy with the brexit deal she's
struck with the European Union but may
warned that I'll sting her would only
delay or even stop progress but now that
may has survived the vote she's adamant
that she will continue her mission we
now need to get on with the job of
delivering brexit for the British people
and building a better future for this
country opposition politicians remain
unconvinced that Teresa mains
Conservative government is fit to cope
this is the further stage in the Tory
party convulsing and arguing and
bringing the bitterness to the surface
over the question of Europe now it's
it's their problem but it does impact
upon the nation it's an absolutely
crucial time May's political survival
can't stop the brexit clock ticking it's
less than four months until the UK is
supposed to leave the EU all right let's
get the latest on the story we have DW
correspondent Charlotte Shelton pillow
standing by for us in London and here in
the studio we have Derek Scalli he's a
correspondent for the Irish Times
newspaper here in Berlin good morning to
you both Charlotte let's start with you
there
what have the reactions there in London
been to Theresa Mays victory
good morning Sumi well I'm sure it comes
as no surprise for you to hear that is
it is the front page of every newspaper
this morning not all of them though
declaring this as a victory as you've
said there if we just look at at the Sun
newspaper the UK is a tabloid newspaper
that headline is time to call it a May
the nice pun there essentially they are
arguing that while she might have won
she is severely weakened and it's it's
time for her to go that of course is
something that she said she would be
doing later down the line she said that
she wouldn't take the country into the
next election in 2022 some would say
that that was part of a concession to
convince her MPs to back her generally
though the newspapers agree that it she
cannot carry on for the next few years
as Prime Minister turning to the next
one the Daily Telegraph let me put that
down it says a vote to remain but when
will she leave that also is asking just
how long can she possibly stay given
that so many MPs voted against us that
they had no confidence in the Prime
Minister now there is one newspaper that
I just want to show you that is a bit
more friendly towards to resume and that
is the Daily Mail it said now let her
get on with the job Maci's off plotters
with two thirds of the party
so it's arguing well we've got our
results now we know now let's get breaks
it done yeah Charlotte that very much
does seem to be the question this
morning Theresa May has won this
confidence vote but her authority has
been damaged in the process what is your
feeling how much has she been weakened
by this challenge to her leadership you
can look at this two ways really I mean
let's be clear this was Theresa May is
no stranger to challenges as Prime
Minister but this was the biggest
challenge to her leadership so far and
she did survive this confidence vote
that's something that wasn't necessarily
guaranteed although yes in the build-up
to the vote people were saying Theresa
May had the votes but there was a lot of
concern and a lot of the British press
were reporting that they were being told
privately by MPs that they didn't have
MPs who publicly said that they
supported her were privately saying
actually actually we're not so sure so
while it was it will be a boost and she
will now be going to Brussels
moving that yes she still largely has
the backing of her MPs
it is a bit of a blow and it has to be
pointed out as well that essentially now
she's back at square one a lot of people
are saying that surviving this
confidence vote is was nothing compared
to the challenge that she faces when it
comes to getting her brexit deals
through Parliament this it must be made
clear was a challenge brought to her by
her own MPs
there is a lot of anger though in the
Parliament in general from opposition
parties about the brexit deal that she
needs to push through Parliament and get
approved in order to leave the European
Union by March 29th
dereck we heard Charlotte Thayer say
she's essentially back at square one so
where does this leave the brexit deal I
would say Tuesday of this week you know
we sat here and we've talked about this
it's like Groundhog Day and the problem
still remains she's going to Brussels
with a problem she cannot solve she has
this issue called the backstop which
we've heard so much about this is the
issue that if if the the Irish just want
the status quo to be a continue
regardless of what happens they do not
want any any experiments on the island
of Ireland and they want that the the
border between the Republic of Ireland
and Northern Ireland will remain open
because if this doesn't happen we will
have Buddha's have chaos they want to
have a regulatory alignment between
Northern Ireland and the Republic of
Ireland if all else fails everyone is
saying we want a better deal we want to
deal for the future of the European
Union
we want a future trading relationship
with Britain that will make any sort of
backstop any sort of insurance policy
and obviate the need for it but and the
Irish are saying we really don't really
trust any anything else we need to be
sure because of the 20 year old peace
process anything that brings the island
of Ireland into new uncertain territory
would be very very difficult for the
Irish for the Northern Irish not just
because of trade because of politics
because of peace and the backstop is on
the table it has always been on the
table it was a problem two and a half
years ago it is a problem today she's
got her MPs or she's got 200 of our MPs
backing her so we're back to where we
were on Tuesday and she's also said
she's not going to run the next election
so she's got her her problems have
really not changed since Tuesday yeah
the question of the Irish backs
certainly has not been solved yet and
it's more significant dark because a
trace amazed government is directly
linked Thailand isn't it yes I mean
she's entered after the last election
she added the last election less support
and then she went into the election so
she had a rather dubious deal with the
DUP that's a unionist party they are one
of the parties to the peace process in
Northern Ireland and she's basically
beholden to them and she has said rather
significantly yesterday she will not do
any deal in Brussels which leaves the
DUP unhappy so this is rather
significant because we do not know
anything and on God's green earth that
will make the DUP happy at the moment
and so she has really just painted
herself yet again into a corner she has
to go to Brussels and find a way to keep
her people in northern aren't happy who
do we not want to be in their view
emotionally or I regularly cut off from
the rest of United Kingdom very good
luck to her I'd say yeah good luck to
her indeed Charlotte coming back to you
now as we heard there from Derek Teresa
Mays heading to Brussels today for an EU
summit she has said that she's looking
for a legally binding commitment that
the Irish backstop will be temporary
what do you think we can expect yeah
she's really going to be going to
Brussels today looking for concessions
from European leaders on this crucial
issue of the Irish border that's as
you've heard that what many think
prompted this confidence vote in her but
Europe has said clearly that they they
are not willing to make concessions
they're more likely to offer her
reassurances about the border than
anything legally binding and then
whether that's going to be enough at
home for them for her to get her brakes
the deal through Parliament well we're
not yet sure yet and we are edging
closer to March 29th and the very real
possibility of leaving the European
Union without a deal
all right DW Charlotte shall simple for
us in London and Dericks Kelly here in
studio thank you both very much